first up she is the representative from
San Francisco she's also the 52nd
Speaker of the House
she just finishing the teaching
president Trump please welcome Nancy
Pelosi
[Applause]
first of all thank you so much for
waiting till we got back on the air
before you started the impeachment and
also before we forget about that
applause you know it was only a year ago
that you were fighting just to be the
Speaker of the House we could be having
Speaker Seth Moulton right now never
really was fighting I thought the press
made more of it but let them have their
fun so you did delay this for a month
and let me just review what happened in
this month we December 20th new emails
revealed that 91 minutes after the
perfect call perfect 91 minutes the
order went out to the Department of
Defense to withhold the aid Lev came
forward a couple of days ago we saw that
he said Trump was personally involved
the Government Accountability Office
that's an official branch of this
government declared Trump broke the law
when he withheld the aid to Ukraine John
Bolton announced he was willing to
testify this all happened during the
delay that people were questioning you
about my question to you is did you know
all this was gonna come out or was this
just a good guess because well let's
just say sometimes it's good to have a
lot of experience well first let me
congratulate you on your opening show
now well thank you very much
and I must say that your opening was
shall we say risque no it was not so
much well I'm sorry I disappointed you
I'll try to work in some profanity
during our interview I was waiting it up
for you they well no the fact is is that
we knew we had a solid case for the
impeachment of the president the facts
were clear the Constitution required it
and we we wanted to make our case and go
forward so we put forth the articles of
impeachment in fact voted them there we
knew there was plenty of other shall we
say information to come forward
but it wasn't necessary to impeach the
president we it would been further
incriminating but not necessary and I'd
wonder in any way we can a case that had
the supports my caucus and I was working
the understood by the American people
you were rather reluctant to do it
compared to a lot of Democrats you want
you waited till it was inevitable where
you couldn't turn away from a thing like
this well he gave us no choice
the president was self impeaching almost
every single day
there are some people who actually have
said that he wanted to be impeached
just for the record being impeached it's
a bad thing right and you're in peace
forever
[Applause]
it can never be erased now President
Trump may be accidentally watching the
show tonight you know he's made me part
of his act because I always say he's not
going to leave if he even if he loses
yeah so you know he's woven that in
because he's a comedian and he does his
rallies you could talk to him directly
because well if I if I knew that he the
president's listening I would want to
accidentally yeah I want him to know
that he is impeached forever and he is
impeached forever because he used the
office of President to have tried to
influence a foreign country for his
personal and political benefit in doing
so he undermined our national security
he was just loyal to his oath of office
to protect the Constitution and he
placed in jeopardy the integrity of our
election and that I mean really he gave
us no choice earlier on with some of the
charges that came forward which were
violations of the law I said he's not
worth it but once he crossed that bridge
it wasn't a question of his being worth
it the Constitution was worth it he had
to do
[Music]
how you began about the timing the value
of that was in the period of that time
now over 70% of the American people want
to see witnesses and documentation to
come forward and that places a burden on
those senators they will either come
down in favor of transparency and
accountability to the Constitution it
will hold them accountable it comes down
to really only four senators I mean from
everything I've heard maybe it's wrong
but there's really only four who are
even considering it and I feel like we
have been down this road so many times
with that small group of moderate
Republicans I'm sure you remember better
than anyone else the Obamacare health
fight when we were waiting and waiting
for you know Lisa Murkowski was it and
Susan Collins and then Brett Kavanaugh
boat and Mitt Romney and there's always
like maybe these moderate Republicans
will come through and always it's the
Charlie Brown football and they don't
what is your prediction about whether
anyone will come through and well we
will have witnesses well it's all about
public opinion Lincoln said public
sentiment is everything with it you can
do anything without it practically
nothing and the public sentiment in
these states is very clearly in favor of
witnesses and documentation and if those
senators don't vote in favor of that
there is a price to pay
now if Mitch McConnell doesn't allow
them to vote for that that says
something as well so they're in a very
bad place but the fact is this is so
clear as far as defending the
Constitution honoring the vision of our
founders for what that is the the
exquisite by separation of powers in our
Constitution that makes us a republic I
pledge allegiance to the fight and to
the Republic for which it stands and
Republic that's what we are that's what
he is undermining by saying article 2
says I can do whatever I was not just
Trump undermining Mitch McConnell you
know I mean you've tipped out right up
to the line of basically calling him on
American and Moscow merge Moscow meant
a lot of ways he's done more damage than
Trump has I mean I know he's a strict
constitutionalist who constantly
violates the Constitution most
prominently of course by not allowing
Merrick garland Obama's Supreme Court
but to even have a hearing well let me
say this and that is if they were to
write the book all the president's men
as they did about it would be called all
the president's henchmen they would
separate the Attorney General of the
United States all these people
surrounding the president but let's just
take this to a patriotic places and
about politics right it isn't about
partisanship
it's about patriotism it's about our
Constitution and we don't want any
president democratic no matter who she
or he is to think that they could get
away with this and he had to be stopped
because he's again jeopardizing the
integrity of the next election by
blaming it on the Ukrainians and not
giving any accountability to the
Russians for what they you're a lot more
generous in spirit to him than I am I've
heard you say to him but to the concept
well I've heard you say I don't I don't
hate anybody I'm right I know and I
believe you I can't go there with you
but here's what I have told my audience
and people disagree with this I told
them and I think this should be our
mantra on the left you can hate Trump
you can't hate the people who like him
no I guess that's where we are - no I'm
unfriending you that way lies literally
civil war I completely agree with even
the people I served with in the Congress
we have very little in common in terms
of our issues but but the fact is I
respect the people who sent them to come
of course and so I afford them the
respect that their constituents deserve
you were never a scary radical but
that's how you were portrayed yeah
137,000 ads describing that way in the
2008 San Francisco which I proudly am
what I found disturbing is that very
often Democrats did not defend you
oh no no good you don't worry about that
you know about that but here's what I do
worry about our country and its
greatness can absorb one term of the
present occupant of the White House not
two terms right what I mean it does to
the courts and the rest so what we have
to do from right to left in our own
party and beyond our own party is to
elect a new president of the United
States
[Applause]
embrace and advance and I have to say as
I travel the country I do believe
there's plenty of common ground in the
mainstream message that can take don't
you think it says something about the
Democratic Party and their inability to
win key elections lately that a lot of
your accomplishments instead of standing
shoulder to shoulder with you and saying
this is the person who saved the country
helped them from going into a depression
by passing the stimulus and save the
automobile industry and got dodd-frank
passed and got health care got Obama
passed you know you're kind of our Iron
Lady here on the Left the Democratic
Party is is very often the victim of
their own purity test I don't worry
about that but I do in terms of a
because I'm in the arena you go in there
you go in and you you have to be ready
to take a punch and you have to be a
throw a punch for the children love the
children what what I am am concerned
about for the children is the future of
this country and we have to have our
common ground a mainstream message now
in the recent election we won we showed
in the house that we know how to win
disciplined focused cold-blooded in
terms of just winning
and good to have your cold-blooded self
[Applause]
you